so I would say - were you to come back
for season two - here you were coming
back back we said very satisfying moment
you know on NCIS we got very spoiled
because every year was sort of assumed
after after the first few years of NCIS
but for a decade or so it was kind of
you know well we know we're going to
come back so let's make hiatus plans and
let's do all that but this was a lot of
unknowns I think what Donald Rumsfeld
called unknown unknowns and so I had a
lot of those feelings but I think we
knew that we had a formula for success
early on with the show and we as we've
been going on we've been refining that
and I think season 2 is going to be an
expansion of character maybe a little
less emphasis on the technology and
explaining how the trial system works
and more about the stories and the
people and kind of stuff I was going to
say how do you avoid a lot of shows get
cursed with it how does bull avoid that
sophomore slump but I guess you kind of
answered it there I think that we have
the you know the incredible talent of a
guy like Glenn Gordon Karen coming in in
season two Glenn created moonlighting
and medium Patricia Arquette and I found
both of those shows to be wildly
different but very compelling and they
both have a real voice and Glenn Karen
writes with a true author's voice and
his fingerprints are going to be all
over this show so I feel that that is
what the show is now going to really be
about expanding our understanding of the
characters by going into very troubled
problematic scenarios and seeing how
they interact so your expertise on the
show
is picking juries for trial you've been
doing it you've been living it for a
little while do you feel like now you're
a good judge of character and like you
can actually do that you could actually
kind of because you've been you know
you've dealt so far in the world and
maybe you could actually pick a jury
like what I make sure what I make a good
juror um I think you would make a
terrific juror uh for the right kind of
case because every case requires a
different group of people said suit it
you know there you want to tailor make
that group as much as you can and I mean
I probably better at it than I would
have been a year ago but I don't think
anyone needs me on their legal team I
think that that I might be more of a
hindrance than anything else at you know
I might just ask a lot of stupid
questions
I'm an actor I like to I like to pretend
and play um Eliza she coming back will
she be back to see that's the great
mystery and I do not know the answer
that question really which is Glenn
Karen and I spoke last night and I said
so I'm doing a big day of press there
anything you want me to talk about and
he said tell them it's all going to be
very interesting and people will be
coming back but I won't say which ones
and I was like okay please give me more
than that
he's very cryptic he's like a mad
scientist kind of genius character
there's Glenn Karen and I he's never
joined a show he's never come in he's
connected with this show because I think
he sees his kind of storytelling and can
work in this world and I think he wants
to put bull through the ringer can you
tell us this there's a rumor that you
might be doing a guest appearance on
NCIS season 15 ain't outside of that
happening I have not heard back from my
lawyer
no NCIS season 15 god that's an
incredible thing to say
a that's a lot of years isn't a lot of
years that's like it's like getting
closer to 20 all the times like 100 and
dollars I don't know what the what the
story is with that but I would never
rule anything out I love NCIS and I
certainly love the character of DiNozzo
and and I miss all my friends over there
particularly the crew who were you know
they were my buddy's role can we one up
that one mm-hmm
can we one up that potentially there's
also talk and you know you have a lot of
fans online and talk there's also talk
that may be a tivo reunion could happen
on a second season of both could you
comment on us
or at least how amazing it would be your
neck with Cody here's what I think is
possible okay in the world in a world of
all where all things are possible
okay I mean except you know can't
reanimate dead people or bit you know I
but we're in the world of you possible
where things are possible nothing's
impossible impossible things are
impossible okay I'm not going to change
that but what does DiNozzo appear on
season 15 of NCIS I have no way of being
able to predict that does Cody come on
to bull in some way I have no way of
predicting that but I think that Tony
believes see what I'm doing with my
fingers did Ziva is still alive but she
hidden from him she's hidden and he's
got to find her he's gotta find her so
I'm hoping that there is some world some
way somehow where there's a Tony and
Ziva moment okay but I don't know when
it's going to be and I don't know how
it's going to be fingers crossed